(audience applause)
- I brought ya a gift.
- First of all, you're invited
any time you bring alcohol.
- [Nick] Yes.
- So wait, what is this?
Villa One--
- So this is my new tequila
with John Varvatos.
- [Kelly] Dang!
- It started about two
and a half years ago.
We started the process of
working' with Stoli Group
to develop our own tequila.
- Um, can we try--
I know this show airs at like 9 AM
and I'm lookin' at you Nashville.
- Just a little bit.
- But yeah, I don't wanna be rude.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So let's do it, Nick.
(audience laughing)
Let's do it.
- Congrats to you.
- My mama raised a polite young lady,
so I will drink your tequila.
- Here's a little bit.
Sorry we don't have enough for everybody.
- I mean fine, I guess we're rationing it,
but it's fine, it's fine.
(audience laughing)
- Here we go, cheers.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience cheering)
- That is good!
It's so smooth!
I was a little nervous
'cause usually I do,
I mean I don't drink ever but--
(audience laughing)
No, I do usually like salt and lime.
That's really smooth!
- Yeah, we're excited about it.
So we just launched this one
- [Kelly] Wow.
- On the east coast and
the rest of the country's
kinda startin' out.
But then we have Reposado
and Anejo as well,
that's comin' out.
- I'm into it!
So okay, let's celebrate real quick.
You want another one?
Okay fine, I will.
(audience laughing)
Let's celebrate and drink to
your first season of The Voice.
You don't have to.
(audience laughing)
Be a better person than
me, I'm tryin' to be kind.
I just wanna celebrate the
fact that you're gonna be
on The Voice and I'm gonna kick your tail.
Oh!
- That's not true.
(audience laughing)
Incorrect.
(cheering)
I'm not gonna clap for that.
- I'm not gonna clap for that,
I refuse to clap for that, ma'am.
- It has been a good
little friendly competition
so far though.
- It has!
- We've done the blinds,
which has been really fun.
My first ever.
Assembled a good team, I
feel confident about it.
- Yes, and we like a lot
of the same sound, yes?
- I didn't expect that.
- I did!
- I thought John and I
would go head to head.
- No.
- But it's really you and I.
- No, I knew it, I knew it.
And the guys were tellin' me.
I was like, "I'm gonna have to
battle Nick freaking Jonas".
(audience laughing)
Like, what?
I'm not gonna win there.
I'm like so not cool
compared to you, like what?